Let's see if we can find out how much x + 7 ...
let me write it a little more clearly:
(x + 7) 2.
I also recommend that you pause the video
and solve it yourself.
Okay, now let's solve it together.
We just have to forget,
that we are lifting the second full-second.
This is the same thing as (x + 7) (x + 7).
I will write the second (x + 7) with a different color,
which will be useful to us,
when we begin to multiply.
When we see it written in this way,
we can multiply it by the way,
by which we multiply all two members.
And I will do it first in the slow but more logical way,
by applying the distribution property twice.
And maybe we will then think of some shorter ways
or any formulas we can use,
especially when we lift two-piece squares.
Let's start by simply applying
distribution property twice.
Explain the brackets and multiply this yellow (x + 7)
on this purple (x + 7).
We can multiply by x, this purple x,
so it will be x ... let's write it with the same color.
This will be purple x (x + 7),
plus purple 7 in yellow (x + 7).
And now we can uncover the brackets
again and multiply.
We can take this purple x
and multiply it by x and by 7.
So x in x is x ^ 2.
x 7 is 7x.
And then we can do it again here.
This 7 - let me write it in a different color,
this 7 will be this
plus another 7x
and then 7 at 7
will be 49.
We're almost in the final rights.
Then we can simplify it.
This is x ^ 2 and then we can collect these two members in the middle.
7h ... let's write it in orange,
7x plus 7x will be 14x.
Plus 14x plus 49.
And we're ready.
The key question here is whether we see some regularity?
Whether we see a model that we can summarize
and who can help us lift two-piece squares
faster in the future?
When we first looked at the multiplication of two-
we saw a formula like
(x + a) (x + b)
will be equal to x ^ 2 ...
Let me write it this way:
is equal to x2 + (a + b) x + b ^ 2.
And if a and b are the same number,
we can say that
(x + a) (x + a) will be equal to x 2 ...
And this is the case when we have
coefficient one in front of the two hiccups.
Now in this case a and b are both a.
So this will be (a + a) x
or we can just say plus 2ah.
Let me know what I have just done.
Instead of writing a + b,
just expressed it as (a + a) on x.
And then plus a ^ 2,
or it is the same thing as
x 2 + 2ax + a ^ 2.
This is the common formula for a two-
raised square.
Two-pointed, squared, the odds of both x are one.
We see that this is exactly the same here.
In this example we did, ours is 7.
So there we get x in a square ... let's surround it.
We have this blue x 2,
which corresponds to that there.
And then 7 is ours,
2ax ... 2 in 7 is 14x.
Note that here we have 14x.
This 14x corresponds to 2ax.
Finally, if a is 7,
and a square is 49.
When you raise a two-piece square,
a quick way to do it is to use this formula here.
And we can quickly make another example,
just to make sure we understand things.
If I tell you, how much is minus ...
will put a minus sign here,
How many (x - 3)? 2?
I recommend that you pause the video
and think about it.
Think about how you will use this formula.
In this case our a ...
we have to be careful ...
ours will be -3,
so this is ours here.
This will be equal to x ^ 2.
Now, 2ah, let me actually write it with the same colors,
just to be fun.
This will be x ^ 2.
Now, how much is 2 x a x?
a is -3, so that 2 is a-6.
This will be -6x.
So, -6x, this is 2 by -3 the coefficient.
And then we have x.
And then plus a ^ 2.
Ok if a is -3,
how much is -3 at -3?
This will be plus 9.
And here, when we look at this formula,
we can find very quickly
how much is this two-piece raised in a square.
And I recommend you do it again,
revealing the braces and multiplying,
to confirm that
this really is equal to (x - 3) ^ 2.